you're watching swype coming up we go on
a tour to TIG work Angela gets an extra
pedal power with one of the latest
electric bikes I get kitted out with
some high tech accessories Tour de
France style and we've got a preview of
the hot new games coming up for release
soon hello and welcome to swipe the Tour
de France is underway so we thought we'd
market with a special cycling themed
episode this week which is why we've
come here to this mountain bike park in
the town of tidworth in southeast
England and it also explains my outfit
I'm all set for later on when i'll be
getting a good look at some advanced
road cycling techy accessories used by
the actual tour de france riders but
before then angela has been zipping
around on an electric bicycle see how
they compared to regular mountain bikes
just how much of an advantage can ebikes
like this one bring you well firstly
they come with integrating notice making
the sport more accessible to those who
may need a little pedal assist so what
else sets them apart from conventional
mountain bikes inside of there is some
very clever technology that just gives
you a little bit more as you put a pedal
stroke in so there's no there's no
throttle to get you going and every time
you push down on the pedals the bike
actually gives you you know 3 4 5 10
pedal strokes more so you've got force
settings on the on the bike eco-tour
sport and turbo and each of those will
give you a little bit more back from the
pedal that you're you're putting in what
settings should i have it on to go up
this hill so always start an eco and as
the he'll get as the hill gets a little
bit steeper you want to just you want to
push that setting up so you can move
into tour and then sport and if the hill
gets really steep push it into to turbo
mode okay and now give you the most out
of the pedal assist and the hill becomes
tremendously easy ok so I'm going to put
it in turbo mode now right let's see oh
yeah very little effort on my part to
get up this hill ok so that was in turbo
mode and I really felt the difference I
was just it was just literally doing all
the work for me but yet I can feel the
weight it's very heavy so I said you
really want to push this bike up a hill
no you would really struggle to push it
up a hill but in something you know this
kind of gradient you'd really need that
turbo mode to get you to the top and
without without a pedal assist bike
you'd probably struggle quite quite
considerably most cyclists would ebikes
can also tell you your speed distance
and range showing you how much battery
life you've got left this usually lasts
about 20 miles but these bikes do you
have drawbacks the main disadvantage is
the weight so we have a big battery here
we have a motor in the bottom and those
two things together at about six or
seven kilos to the way to the bike so
that's about half as much again as a
normal bike a basic ebike is also more
than double the price of a mid-range
conventional mountain bike which could
be why they haven't really taken off in
the UK but government-funded loan
schemes could help see that change
giving power to a new breed of cyclist
Angela Barnes Sky News
stay with us still to come are we
teaming my fetching road cycling outfit
with some advanced rider accessories
that's to come right after a summary of
this week's tech news to take away
companies are about to start using
robots to deliver food just eat and
pronto have partnered with starship
technologies which makes slow-moving
automated vehicles to start the trial in
London the delivery bots will be able to
travel at speeds of up to four miles per
hour and use GPS and cameras to find
their way to your home and NASA space
probe successfully entered orbit around
Jupiter this week dunno arrived at the
largest planet in the solar system after
a five-year 1.7 billion mile journey
from Earth it'll now spend 20 months
discovering what's under Jupiter's thick
clouds measuring water content magnetic
fields and searching for signs of a
solid core BMW is set to develop
driverless car technology with Intel and
computer vision firm mobile I the three
companies will work together on the
systems needed to make vehicles that can
navigate and drive safely without humans
behind the wheel bMW says it hopes it
can bring the cars into production by
2021 and a kite designer in Taiwan has
been showing off his latest flying
creation it's a kite bike if you hadn't
already guessed made of polyester panels
to catch the wind and carbon beams for
the structure the 200 centimeters high
and its creator Fang Zhang Wang says it
only weighs naught point 8 kilograms and
in case you're wondering he designed it
for a children's folklore festival stick
around as we take to the high seas in
our games preview with Chris but first
let's talk accessories now and not just
any accessories but some of the items
that are expert here Rosie is about to
show us the same as the ones being used
by the actual tour de france riders and
you're about to kick me out with some
bits okay so this is the one helmet from
ballet it's actually four helmets in one
which makes it really economical which
means you can use it as a road helmet a
mountain bike helmet a commuter helmet
but you can also use it as an aero
helmet you can block up the helmets
which allows up the vents which allows
that air to go straight over rather than
to circulate around I don't need to cut
it through it really make a difference
to speed it does yet it allows you to
cut through when the air more
efficiently rather than it circulating
around and causing resistance that'll
slow you down okay one of these okay so
these are the oakley jawbreaker prism
road glasses you'll see those throughout
the peloton as well on riders such as
Mark Cavendish funny purpley color they
are very powerfully gala so the lens is
tuned to adapt the colors of the road
which means that you can pick up on
small contours you know bits of debris
things like that far more efficiently
does it really make a difference then in
bright light to another normal pair of
sunglasses if you come in down the hill
at a decent amount of speed being
reactive is really important I'm
standing rather awkwardly but that's
because of the shoes I'm wearing yeah
this is the s-works six you from
specialized their design for the
ultimate in power transfer so they've
got a carbon soul in a really thin
footbed which means that you don't lose
anything in the soul and it keeps keeps
your foot nice and stiff can all of this
kit make a difference as somebody who
isn't a professional cyclist they just
want to go out for a little trip the
weekend with any kit the more you invest
the better quality you tend to find that
it is in the better performance it gives
you and at the end of the day it's all
about comfort and enjoyment and having
fun the more comfortable you are the
more fun you'll have so you ever get to
the point where you're getting a little
bit bored of seeing manufacturer after
manufacture come out with the next best
thing claiming to be even better for the
riders every now and then somebody does
come out with something new and really
exciting and it's the next step and it's
all about evolution and development
and you never know what's going to come
next Rosie thank you or any now is a
team and a climb
now the summers generally a mild time
for new video games releases but they
are coming so what's in store and will
they be worth the wait here's Chris with
a preview one-night stand is a game made
by just two people and it deals with the
idea of you wake up in the morning you
don't know where you are and there's
someone laying next to you and from
there on in you decide what happens and
it's a wonderful little game it's got
beautiful sort of rotoscoped visuals
which is where you know you draw over an
actual film and the matter this is made
by two people is amazing you kind of get
to go into the headspace of someone else
which is one of the amazing things that
video games can do they can actually put
you in the position of someone else
rather than like a film or a book wave
and then you'd sort of leading by the
author's own narrative in a video game
you can kind of make the decision
yourself hey girl in the little demo
version they've made there's like six
endings or so but the full games coming
out at some point this year there's
going to be way more different endings
and all of this is just based on how you
talk to the person if you talk to the
person you could just get up and leave
who knows but it's an amazing beautiful
game you go on a website called each dot
IO you can find it there and you can
download the thing for free so check out
I don't think she's gonna say yes that
look like yes face CF Yves is a game
that I wasn't initially sold on the
first time you saw it which was last
year a free it kind of just showed you a
big open world and it was kind of
colorful but yeah he didn't have too
much but this time when they showed you
it your pirates in a big open world and
you kind of just do what you want they
showed people playing it which made a
huge difference so you had like three
different teams of people and it showed
them all figuring out how to pilot their
ship and they have to work together like
you have to the sales and all that stuff
and just watching these people delight
in figuring out how to use their
so then as they get sailing realizing
our there's other teams in other boats
should we attack them yeah why not it'll
be fun and then their boat leaking and
trying to patch it up and he look crazy
Bruntlett you can imagine playing it
with a bunch of friends online have been
like yeah we've got our boat and we
pilot it and we go around and the
world's really colorful and beautiful
which is sort of something that rare was
known for and I can't wait now looks fun
I want to play with friends and that
should be out next year Detroit is a
game made by otter which is a really
fancy name that lots of us like to use
but it just means guy that comes up with
the whole idea you already knew that
dunno why I'm telling you David cage and
his team Quantic Dream who are best
known for the game heavy rain this is a
sort of Blade Runner type story which is
androids existing in the future people
trust androids and there's people that
don't like Android most of the time he's
got a story to tell but the most recent
trailer we saw a free please showed an
Android detective and the amount of
different things that your decisions
could lead to or crazy it really felt
like it was delivering on the promise
that he made ages ago which was you're
not going to have the same story as
anyone else and your decisions are
really going to man the more you play
the game and it just looks nice I mean I
don't know at what point will get used
to the idea that these new consoles look
amazing but her for years and I still
haven't it looks standing so I can't
wait the player
well that's it for this week take a good
look at Sky News on mobile tablet
catch-up sky cute and snapchat for all
the latest sex stories I'll see you
again next week bye-bye